[Musique]
bien vu dans cette troisième édition des
prix vidéo art convergence on va en
parler avec vous laurence du pain vous
est la fondatrice de ce prix on venait
de nous expliquer en quoi il consiste et
il ya avec vous deux membres du jury on
aura un troisième qui est eric altmayer
qui nous rejoindre à tout à l'heure
c'est drôle si alan picard
il faut présenter peut-être
vous êtes réalisatrice de films de
fictions documentaires
vous êtes aussi raide et réalisatrice de
pièces de théâtre multimédia et vous
avez obtenu le grand prix vidéo en 2018
je crois pour un film qui s'appelait de
metz ce serait ça et puis à côté de vaud
jean-christophe vignolles bonjour vous
êtes médecin psychiatre vous êtes
responsable de l'interface sdf de la
ville de lyon on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure parce que c'est vrai
c'est intéressant et vous êtes aussi
passionné par les rapports entre le
cinéma et les psychiatres ips que vous
même vous êtes vous organisé un festival
de cinéma et de psychiatrie de festivals
de cinéma de vinatier à lyon rien que ça
alors laurence du pas je vais me tourner
vers vous le but de ce prix je crois que
cette sensibiliser au fond le public
ou à la réalité que vivent les personnes
qui souffrent de maladies psychiques
c'est bien ça oui c'est une c'est à
c'est un des aspects de ce prix et s'est
aussi montré de ne pas forcément montré
la maladie 6,6 et interpeller le public
à travers des oeuvres et pas uniquement
de manière littérale
donc voilà c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé
de créer ce prix en ouvrant à tous les a
tous c'est pas uniquement
fait pour les personnes qui sont
directement concernés ou ceux qui
s'occupent de personnes malades
vont sélectionner filmées au fond l'idée
de ce prix je crois qu'il est né en 2013
essai de fruits d'abord à la fois d'une
conviction qui est la vôtre et puis deux
rencontres aussi c'est le fruit de du
d'un premier travail qui a été exposé à
la manger du domaine de madame elisabeth
il ya un travail vidéo a réalisé par
pierre leroy dans lequel il a il a
finalement interpellé un tout public en
nous disant voilà moi je souffre de
schizophrénie quand on va mal en train
de montrer mal ou vous traitent mal
quand tout va bien on vous traite bien
qu'ils étaient des évidences et
finalement ce que cette vidéo sous un
format très court elle a eu un impact
voiles affalées de révéler exactement et
du coup on s'est dit voilà il faudrait
créer quelque chose parce qu'il ya
peut-être matière à réaliser qu'elle a
montré les choses autrement et à travers
des oeuvres
différentes infos pour les chances à sa
vision des maladies psychiques 80 mo
avec aujourd'hui j'en ris au viol on y
reviendra tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai
que
ces rapports puisque nous mêmes vous
devez vous y consacrer entre le cinéma
et la maladie qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
est important c'est le regard que les
gens peuvent avoir sur la maladie c'est
le regard des malades qui peuvent avoir
sur eux mêmes mais ce qui est important
effectivement c'est le regard aussi
tiers qui est celui du cinéaste c'est à
dire que effectivement ça pour le dans
les journées cinéma psychiatriques on a
monté à lyon l'a t rès était de montrer
avant tout pour soignants c'est à dire
de montrer finalement ce que vous vivez
les personnes par un regard tiers qui
est celui du cinéaste c'est à dire c'est
d'aller les personnes soit les personnes
mêmes leurs films soient effectivement
le cinéaste à un autre regard que
que les soignants notre idée était de
passer des films documentaires pour que
l'espace pour que les soignons soit
enseignée d'une certaine manière par les
patients sur leur souffrance sur ce
qu'ils vivaient sur leur singularité et
aussi un peu une manière de sortir de
l'autre soit
des hôpitaux psychiatriques mais il ya
eu plusieurs mouvements enfin peut-être
par le grand nord par là parce que total
est
laurence il ya évidemment un appel à
projets alors comment comment ça se
passe au monde est comme ça dès que vous
en vous envoie des courts métrages on se
donne un petit peu de temps en fait on
diffuse a effectivement l'appel à
projets quelques mois avant de
réceptionner les films et en général on
roule cadre sur le format donc un format
très court parce que c'est quelque chose
qui est du coup facile facile à diffuser
on le on diffuse largement au près
toutes les formations à la communication
par l'image pour éviter justement de
rester dans l'entretoit de la
psychiatrie qui mue à la clé a ses
limites aussi jeu presque disait jean
christophe et on l'adresse aussi à tous
ceux qui vont être les communicants de
demain à travers l'image cher qu'en fait
on l'envoie aux écoles de bosa aux
écoles de cinéma aux écoles de
journalisme d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
que darty a été on ferait d'irak et la
table quand elle a participé c'est grâce
à cet appel j'étais dans une école de
journalisme à dépôts non en fait c'était
une copine française à moi qui je pense
qu'elle avait été impliquée charlotte
elle avait été impliqué dans le travail
que faire comme l'argent c'est elle qui
me l'a envoyé mais c'était pire moment
où je pensais à tourner un film sur le
sujet de la bipolarité et donc avant les
restrictions les restreint de faire un
film qui dure pas plus que 4 minutes et
tout ça a aidé le progrès littaye bien
sûr mais qui était quand même étudiant
pour tous la fête était en train de
téter à la liberté qui vous est un
mastodonte et c'était quand même dans le
cadre d'études même si c'est pas
exactement auprès de ton école qu'on
avait diffusé le prix nous verrez c'est
pour vous dire que dimanche je pense que
c'est intéressant d'avoir des personnes
qui participent qui sont d'horizons très
divers
du coup s'intéressent au sujet par ce
biais là et l'idée de ma des dotations
c'est aussi quelque part enfin des
dotations sont pas négligeables c'est
important aussi parce que ça ça donne
envie ça permet d'apporter une
reconnaissance au travail qu'ils
réalisent sur les dotations justement il
ya 2500 euros pour le grand prix 1500
euros pour le prix du jury et 1000 euros
pour le prix du public et on révélera
les voilà des prix
le thème de cette année c'est il faut
bien vivre avec une maladie psychique
oui exactement avec cette idée que bon à
la fois il faut bien
soumettent aux porteurs autres sont
accommodés et puis il faut bien avec lui
cette idée il faut bien lire là ça peut
être de l'humour ça peut être beaucoup
de chose de génial parce qu'en fait tous
vivent pas malheureusement et il ya
souvent énormément de talent énormément
d'humour énormément de belles choses que
vivent ces gens qui ont des maladies
psychiques dit qui d'ailleurs le le le
disent pas toujours et le vif des à des
degrés différents et de diverses
manières mais enfin message c'est de
dire on peut atteindre était il faut
bien de façon d'ailleurs le bout il faut
on en parlera tout à l'heure peut-être
avec vous aussi peut être four peut
l'écrire et faillite et au poète
écrivain phoenix il ya des des jeux avec
je donne la composition du jury
alors d'or de jean christophe pignol et
de retiers à le niqab il ya donc eric
altmayer il ya sandrine bretin qui est
directrice générale de la fondation elle
fait pas partie du jury elle a été
maintenant parce qu'en fait c'est un de
nos partenaires mais je vais là d'accord
c'est pas bien le roi il une idée pas
dans le jeu et non plus ils ont
participé à la sélection pour d'autres à
4 113 sélections à la sélection pas la
sélection finale mais à la presse
élections parce qu'en fait on moi je
veux revenir relation on reçoit beaucoup
de films il faut déjà faire une première
sélection je suis
la thématique sur le
quand il sort quand ils sont pas dans la
thématique ni dans la durée sont éliminé
d'emblée puisque un règlement et après
il faut aussi faire on ne peut pas
demander aux jurés de regarder 60 vidéos
même si elle dure 4 minutes
voilà donc effectivement on se fond se
fait aider par des personnes qui ont la
gentillesse de toutes les regarder donc
avoir le même regard de de la première à
la 60e est-ce que dorothy a fait aussi
parce que certains membres d'équipage en
ligne et donc en kaki journaliste et
rédacteur en chef du quotidien du
pharmacien était dans le jury oui tout à
fait un
essai net d'abb
directeur de la fiction du mur et de
france télévisions
évidemment il faut monter un festival
comme celui là il faut des partenaires
il faut des dz il ya notamment alors
quelqu'un qui vous avait dit que c'est
serré cette 10 ème département des
yvelines et la mairie de plaisir et je
vous propose de regarder le message qu'a
voulu vous adresser joséphine coleman ce
berger et une de vos partenaires dans ce
festival
d'abord à côté proches et presque j'irai
à ses petits fils puisque avait
convergence se réinstaller à l'hôpital
de plaisir dans notre centre hospitalier
et puis aussi parce que je connais bien
la présidente laurence duban qui est
présidente et qui a toujours des idées
d'extraordinaire pour accompagner les
personnes qui sont je dirais atteintes
de handicap en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que en tant que vice
présidente à la culture je crois que
cette idée de vidéos est une idée
extraordinaire parce que ça permet de
développer toute une
possibilités artistiques que ce soit au
niveau documentaire que ce soit au
niveau fiction et ça donne vraiment eu
une ouverture importante dans
différentes catégories
d'accompagnement que ce soit en tant que
comédien ou en tant que techniciens
autour de la vidéo donc pour moi il me
semblait important que le département
soit omniprésent est présent dans cet
accompagnement de projets en tant que
maire de plaisir je suis très fier car
et convergence par le biais de sa
présidente soit toujours dans des idées
remarque abl de ce respect justement de
cette forme de culture avec le handicap
et puis je tenais à dire aussi que je
pense que le ministère de la culture
avec la nouvelle ministre doit avoir un
regard particulier mais je sais qu'elle
là mais je peux être que je lui enverrai
un courrier pour lui dire il faut
accompagner tout c'est tout c'est tous
ses engagements là qui sont vraiment je
dirais fondamental aujourd'hui les
personnes qui sont atteintes de maladies
psychiques ont vraiment leur rôle dans
la culture et elles sont indispensables
je dirais pour faire comprendre les
difficultés qu'ils vivent au quotidien
voilà donc c'est vrai que
au plus de 2
de vous ouvrir le ministère de la
culture s'est dit que ce serait une
bonne chose que
d'autres partenaires et
d'autres partenaires et je vais d'abord
comment continuer dans la lignée à max
est tout particulièrement centre
hospitalier de plaisir mais parce qu on
est hébergée géographiquement dans un
bâtiment tout neuf qu'on vient
d'inaugurer
et c'est vrai qu'il est partenaire de
longue date les de l'association
france général et maire de plaisir et
elle est conseillère départementale
c'était de ces deux rôles laquelle quel
est donc en fait on a eu d'autres
partenaires effectivement pour le prix
vidéo on a le partenariat de la ville de
paris la ville de paris effectivement
inscrit le soutient encore sans que nos
gens qui ont des maladies psychiques
dans ses objectifs prioritaires
le psy comme qui est un organisme de
formation et d'information autour de la
santé mentale et dont la directrice en
tout cas est assez présente aux côtés de
l'association il favorise le justement
l'idée des dotations et la diffusion des
vidéos
on a aussi d'une femme qui est une
association qui aide aide aux familles
de personnes souffrant de maladies
psychiques
l'académie des beaux-arts qui était
d'une certaine manière un lien avec la
culture directement ce qui est assez
rare ce qui est très intéressant par
rapport à nos projets et d'une
reconnaissance qu'on apprécie
particulièrement
on a et on a un partenaire historique
très important dans l'ensemble de nos
projets et tout particulièrement pour le
prêt vidéo qui la fondation falret
voilà
juste quand vous dire la fondation
falret c'est quand même un acteur très
important dans le champ de la santé
mentale parce qu'il suit le quotidien de
trois mille cinq cents personnes en
ile-de-france et dans les outrances ils
sont pas à lyon encore
à travers des différents types
d'accompagnement qui permettent
l'insertion sociale ou l'insertion
professionnelle même parfois avec
déserté donc voilà les partenaires de
partenariat alors je vais peut être
essayer à vous dotez et jean-christophe
de christophe pignol
avant de parler du tour du du festival
et dark convergence
je souhaiterais que vous paraît que
votre action justement à lyon
vous avez vous occupé d'une équipe
psychiatrique qui qui va vers les sdf
c'est à dire que il y à
des équipes mobiles psychiatrie
précarité ça s'appelle
pour aller au-devant des sdf c'est à
dire de tous ceux qui sont en mesure
finalement de formuler une demande et
c'est vrai qu'on intervient à la demande
toujours les travailleurs sociaux du
samu social et du coup on va dans la rue
on n'a pas de bureau et on était bien là
où sont les gens dans les accueils de
jour de nuit de
dans les foyers et voilà on est toute
une équipe d'une dizaine de personnes
dont les deux médecins cinq infirmiers
de
deux psychologues et on fait ça depuis
c'est bien qu'il ya une vingtaine
d'années il essaie un seul sur lyon pour
s'occuper de la prise en charge des sdf
de lui reprendre dans le contexte du
confinement c'était une pratique très
compliqué et c'est une pratique très
intéressante parce qu'effectivement le
but est d'amener ces personnes en
souffrance psychique ou malades mal on
suppose value des études à le tuer mais
qui a beaucoup de weeds
psychiatrique les statistiques sont
extrêmement difficiles à faire mais il
ya une statistique française qui disent
qu'ils s'appellent samantha qui date de
2009 qui est à celle qui est la plus
valides et invalides et dans les autres
pays européens on retrouve à peu près
les plaisirs il ya un tiers des
personnes à la rue qui ont une maladie
mentale constituent est atteint de
troubles psychiatriques
antérieure à la la la la rue par contre
la rue mobilise des défenses quiros qui
s'inspire sans la psychose des défenses
un peu paranoïaque pour dormir à la
jebba il faut être sur le qui-vive r il
ya la peur on a peur d'être persécutés
parce qu'on l'ait aussi vraiment et donc
il ya tout un cortège de défense us ichi
pour survivre qui est qui s'apparente à
la psychose et qui donne des états quasi
psychotique donc la rue rend aussi
les voilà les deux phénomènes joue mais
il ya quand même un tiers des personnes
à la rue qui sont des personnes
la demande malades dos en se la
psychiatrie car devant
donc ça c'est votre ça c'est bon que tu
es 10 h 56 du mans je reviens au cinéma
aux rapports entre le cinéma la
psychiatrie vous dites vous font qu est
important qu'il est tel film qui fait à
la fois et par des personnes concernées
et par des créateurs c'est à dire qui
est de regarder interne c'est peu dire
et pris un regard extime où
le regard extime le regard de l'autre le
regard du créateur ou le regard de la
personne ça change du regain que la
psychiatrie porte sur les personnes
c'est à dire qu'on a beau nous avoir des
tas de théories
je pense que un patient qui ou qui fait
sa fiction qui kills ou la création
artistique donne vérité notre vérité de
la vie de la personne et pour nous au
tout départ ces jeux
c'était comme un cheval de troie c'est à
dire qu'on voulait introduire dans le
temps dans l'hôpital psychiatrique des
vécus de personnes qui ont été malades
pour enseigner pour enseigner les
soignants et ça c'est très important que
la déstigmatisation aussi de la maladie
mentale il affole à déstigmatiser aussi
auprès d'eads et des soignants et des
médecins généralistes les soignants sont
là aussi on est formaté à dire c'est
très grave ils peuvent pas vivre ces
deux maladies chroniques hockey silva
dit chronique mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'on peut pas vivre quand on est
schizophrène je pense qu'on peut tout à
fait avoir alors maintenant ville et
enfin du tout à fait correct on
utilisait concept de rétablissement ça y
est des modes au niveau des idées mais
je pense qu'on tout à fait et monte on
de montrer un la souffrance
par le cinéma par l'émotion que peuvent
ressentir certaines personnes mais aussi
l'originalité la singularité de certains
parcours et que effectivement peut avoir
et ça y est le cinéma la vidéo qui fait
qu'il peut le blâmer il ya une
stigmatisation très forte dans la
société
c'était une motivation très forte et du
coup maintenant nos journées bon ça fait
une dizaine d'années on les a ouvertes
aux familles on les a ouvertes aux
personnes concernées ont
signalé au départ c'était au vinatier
maintenant ses trois hôpitaux
psychiatriques sont mis ensemble pour
concours quand les maintiennent et on
voudrait même passer à autre chose
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grand
public et en dehors de l'hôpital je
pense que ça y est on a quand même gagné
un peu au niveau d'aidé soignant et on a
un petit peu ont convaincu les les
soignants que qu'effectivement par ce
médium là on pouvait toucher quelque
chose de la maladie plus autant que les
descriptions clinique théorique et ça
c'est par le sensible par la faim la
part l'arrêt c'est pour ça que les les
petites vidéos d'art urgence nous on
aime bien les passer entre deux films
parce qu'on passe essentiellement des
documents d'un documentaire quand on
enlève tout ce qui est journalistique on
essaie de trouver des documentaires de
création comme on dit on va les chercher
à lussas dans deux festivals en belgique
et tout mais souvent c'est un peu lourd
que vous avez un après midi vous avez
un documentaire sur l'a16 qui est suivi
par ge pas documentaire sur le vécu des
familles on est suicidé
les petits docu et les petits films ou
des films ou des petits films faits par
des patients qui rend peu d'humour ça ça
allège nouvelle année et en plus ça
permet
de parler des convergences mais aussi de
les diffuser
d'invités vérité
manificat puisque vous êtes réalisatrice
et nast je rappelle vous avez le leurs
prix en 2018 pour ms et vous dites vous
aux fonds le cinéma et peut permettre
d'aborder des situations que les mots
peut-être aurait du mal à dire oui
exactement et je pense que mon premier
abord quand je fais un film je pense au
sujet je je je pense à tous les éléments
différents qui forme qui fait un film
qui font un film donc pas peut-être la
musique tu as de la dialogue il ya
l'image j'aime bien pensé ok ok moi je
ris anti quoi je j'ai des gens tentent
des choses je sens des choses tactile tu
sens des choses affectif comment est ce
que tu vas traduire une expérience
sensuelle ont une expérience qui est
vraiment intérieur à l'image à la
sonorité comme ça et tu es je pense que
pour ça le
le cinéma c'est mon avis c'est le seul
médium qui permet vraiment de d'aborder
des sujets des vécus qui qui sont un
outil mkii son intérieur par
par plein de milieux différents vous
aimez quand l'image parle d'elle même ou
faux quand y'a pas besoin de souligner
par forcément là je dialogue il ya des
gens qui disent que le meilleur cinéma
c'est
imaginer passer tel c'est ça et ça c'est
les bases du ciment est pour moi surtout
avec la fiction tout d'abord essayé de
communiquer les choses justes avec des
gestes avec des regarde avec des choses
plus incarné et puis pour se dire le
deuxièmement
parce que quand même c'est ça qui est
universel c'est le comportement c'est
les jette ses touches acquis communiqué
et je pense que voilà si tu fais si tu
mets muet faire des films c'est
intéressant de voir quel quel film parle
sans même avoir trop de dialogues je
pense que dire des fois c'est sûr
utilisé neuf serre souligne quelque
chose qui est vraie alors que l'on parmi
ces films
qui parlent pas l'image que vous aimez
beaucoup c'est qu'ils s'appellent
l'escalier de l'oxi était de naguib et
tavares abel je vous propose qu'on
regarde un extrait et laurence du pain
alors vous allez nous quitter quelques
instants vous viendrez tout à l'heure et
on va y est on va alors on est obligé
c'est à cause des conditions sanitaires
on peut pas être plus nombreux sur le
plateau d on va on va accueillir un
autre monde pour des durées qui eric
altmayer et on regarde d'abord un
extrait de l'escalier de l'anxiété
[Musique]
ouah
on
voilà c'était donc un extrait de
l'escalier de look cité film que vous
avez particulièrement apprécié parce que
nos fait l'image parle parle d'elle-même
et donc c'est très calme ailleurs
bonjour
vous êtes vous êtes producteur êtes de
confondateur de monde un cinéma et
mandarin tv vous êtes produit beaucoup
de films pour des oss-117 dont brice de
nice dont les films de doses ont
notamment 1
qu'est ce qui vous a intéressé vous en
tant que
producteur de films de fiction notamment
dans ceux dans ce festival ce prix art
convergence
d'une manière générale je suis très
favorable au festival et surtout au
festival de courts métrages deux
premiers films je pense que c'est une
opportunité inouïe quand on a l'ambition
de se lancer dans une carrière de
réalisateur que de se confronter à a
défait à des festivals de se confronter
à des jurys à du public
ce qui est particulièrement fort dans le
cadre du prix art convergence c'est que
je pense que la thématique de la maladie
mentale de la maladie psychique
appel
à une acte créatif forts comme le disait
de roffit à l'instant le le cinéma c'est
la possibilité d'évoquer sans sans le
dire noir sur blanc c'est la possibilité
de toucher et d'émouvoir
quand on a une thématique à défendre une
défaite une thématique aussi noble je
pense que le lien avec le cinéma et la
formule du court métrage est les
parfaits et en plus vous nous dites
parce que évidemment c'est il ya ce
festival consterne évident les gens qui
sont atteints par une maladie
psychiatrique
concept des psys câbles mais vous dites
c'est aussi intéressant pour les
cinéastes ou futurs cinéastes de
participer à des festivals comme celui
là très je pense que c'est vraiment là
la voix surtout aujourd'hui où en fait
il ya une distinction qui se fait de
plus en plus nette entre on va dire les
la création des images pour les
plateformes et les chaînes de télévision
je pense que le festival
a eu devient moment la voie royale pour
les pour permettre d'émerger ou de faire
émerger des réalisateurs ou des nouveaux
auteurs en plus pour nous producteurs et
les gens du métier
avec le temps l'expérience on perd un
peu l'habitude de se re confronté
justement à la création surtout au
premier film au premier court métrage
est pour moi un titre personnel le fait
de se re baigner dans dans la sélection
de tous les films c'est aussi une
expérience extrêmement enrichissante
ça me permet de voir effectivement
comment évolue la créativité
chez des la nouvelle génération puisque
en général et les réalisateurs de courts
métrages de la sélection sont assez
jeunes
et puis ça permet de se confronter aussi
aux manières parfois très différentes
sur un même thème avec lesquelles les
différents réalisateurs adressent la
question il ya peut-être un peut-être un
petit regret que vous pouvez exprimer
enfin je ne sais pas si c'est il est
vrai mais
il ya beau dit au fond on pourrait on
pourrait peut-être plus traiter ce thème
du côté de la fiction un peu plus du
clae de la fiction que ça ne l'a été non
mais on a été tous je pense les membres
du jury à ses marques et de voir que
cette sélection
probablement un signe des temps onel une
année compliquée oui mais cette
sélection était très noir enfin très
rude et surtout la façon dont la
thématique de la maladie mentale a été
abordé de façon très frontal très direct
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs on a vu dans la sélection
une majorité de documentaires qui
adresse qui traite fondamentalement et
de manière très forte à la question il
faut bien vivre avec une maladie
psychique mais
sans
s'en passer effectivement par les
aspects métaphorique symbolique ou
émotionnel que peuvent développer de
façon plus facilement la fiction je
pense que la dureté du thème et la
dureté des temps a fait que les plupart
des scénaristes ont choisi une voie
frontale et documentaires ou alors le
recours aux films d'animation très
présent on verra quelques extraits de
films d'animation permet probablement de
prendre d'autres était la thématique
assez dramatique d'un peu de sujets avec
avec un peu plus de poésie et de
légèreté y'a rien des membres du jury
qui est paquet d'idées du camp qui dit
sans trahir ni n'est ni la souffrance
des patients au fond les films et je
voudrais vous interroger tous les trois
là dessus les films parviennent parfois
à rendre belle la maladie psychique vous
partagez cette
cette analyse nos sentiments
je pense que l'image peut être belle
mais je suis
plus sceptique qui
la rendent cocasse pu rendre une une
redonnez l'originalité nous notre
spécial on a beaucoup de documentaires
et c'est vrai qu'il ya certains
cinéastes qui file qui suivent qui
filent d'aider des personnes qui ont
quand même une loufoquerie une
originalité et une singularité et on a
de très bon portrait comme ça de deux
patients qui sont et qui soit c'est beau
à voir dans leur folie alors après il
faut pas être du ces du montage le
cinéma fait un
très beau film devrait passer cette
année qu'on passera sûrement l'année
prochaine can un portrait qui a été fait
pas qu'une femme est qui et qui est très
drôle qui est très sensible et plein de
poésie bon depuis shekels réhospitalisé
quand même donc voilà donc auront
dévoilé sa saisie aussi des instants des
moments la vie n'est pas linéaire et
qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de drôlerie et
de mais ça rend très sensible va le
cinéma je rejoins complètement dorothée
un cessez le rôti pardon c'est quand
même
c'est quand même par cette
sensibilité là qu'on transmet il ya
quelque chose de l'affect m-watch est
extrêmement important que les soignants
puisse savoir cet enseignement de la
part d'eads et les soignent les publics
il est public et le public et moi je
vous n'êtes pas nous qui se dit athée et
le public fait partie effectivement les
gens souffrent quand même justement
puisque on va continuer à parler des
produits des soignants vous êtes avec
deux extraits
enfin deux films passer des extraits
parce que vous souhaitez peut-être
insisté tout sur eux parce que ils
prennent le point de vue des personnes
qui sont concernées par la maladie et
le premier extrait peut-être vous pouvez
nous en parler avant que le passé
quelques saisons dans les films on aille
il ya eu il y avait quand même 40 films
à voir j'avais deux films que j'ai vous
coupez mais c'est cacophonie de l'uci
clervoy voilà parce qu'effectivement on
perçoit exactement ce que décrivent les
patients dans leur souffrance quand les
mots par exemple des mots blessent mais
blesse au sens pas métaphorique qui
blesse dans la chair c'est à dire que
quand il ya une très belle salle de
petit déjeuner où on voit bien comment
elle est agressée par les mots
directement et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on voit dans la clinique
psychiatrique couramment des personnes
qui sont blessées par le langage par un
bruit quelque chose mais qui va au delà
du du sursaut du contenu de ce qui est
dit c'est le seul mot qui rentrent dans
la chaussée les noms qui en arrachait si
les menant sa tête des mots dans cette
crise et aussi les mots dans sa tête il
est de ces formidables effectivement
dans cette fête j'ai envie dit rien n'a
beaucoup de films qui le font les mots
dans la tête sa tournée là on sent là je
crois que c'est l'expression avoir enfin
caen caen la mer pain au petit déjeuner
et que s'apprend et ça il ya beaucoup de
choses très basiques la mairie déjeuner
j'avais en hd fait des confitures j'ai
dû quoi un truc comme ça en fin de cycle
ici tu l'envoies les psychologues cette
information et on va donc voir ce court
extrait ans a fait de ce court métrage
qui s'appelle cacophonie bonjour ma
chérie
a bien dormi
[Musique]
s'en fout de toi en paix tu veux je te
fasse une partie
14,6 que tu tiens à la maison
médicaments avec tom insurgés
alors qu'est ce que tu vas bien sûr
après midi j'utilise pas mon
organisation vote du bureau sont
donc en tout cas si tu vas y allait être
au rendez vous oui ils ont voyagé à 3,8
bien incapable de tenir a envie de
goûter un accident d un accident mais tu
t'en souviens que je peux pas ta
compagne compagnie s est mal à jabot
histoire la maison
blanche les créoles tétreault rendez
vous oui
jaya laitue à partir un petit peu en
avance aussi
de parler comme ça m'a plu écoute moi je
te parle gentiment je suis une jolie
table je me sens un petit peu tout seul
en fait
c'est
parce que comme vous dis ça par de très
bons sentiments tout à fait et là on
voit aussi comment les voiles et
voiliers qui sont ces personnages c'est
en fait c'est vous c'est un surdoué et
c'est vrai que tu ailles quand la
personne dans la réalité parle ça
dérange aussi les voiles et que on peut
pas toucher en même temps alors il ya un
autre extrait que vous souhaiteriez voir
à l'arrivée vous intéressez un mot c'est
les normaux pas tu sais quoi êtes vous
ne pouvez pas d'énormes au pad c'est
normalement nous
sheila les soignants c'est là qu'on a
les représentants de la norme c'est est
ce qu'on doit être et c'est cela qui
disent il faut faire comme ça il faut
faire comme ça ça c est la psychiatrie
est actuellement bon on va pas rentrer
dans les détails psychiatrique est basé
sur le trouble c'est une petite équipe
basée sur la norme ça c'est quand même
la psychiatrie contemporaine actuelle
mairie comme ça ce sera un autre débat
beaucoup plus long et j'ai beaucoup aimé
ce petit film qui s'appelle il faut il
faut parce qu'effectivement c'était la
jonction il joue avec les mots
jouabilité est
x et puis c'est surtout
un film qui a été fait je crois à une
personne concernée un patient pendant ce
confinement c'est fait avec trois bouts
de ficelle et le film tient bien la
route il est plein d'humour et c'est
effectivement il joue avec 7,2
injonction permanente
il faut il faut il faut il faut de
réaliser les font vivre il faut même
vivre avec la maladie le réalisateur
s'appelle li antoine doit nous dire un
petit extrait du double qu'il faut
chercher
chercher des soignants soignante qui
sont capables d'entendre que je peux
aller mieux si c'est moi qui leur dit
que je peux aller mieux qu'ils me croit
quand je leur dis que je peux aller
mieux
je les teste il faut il me faut les
tester
je ne peux pas me fier à n'importe qui
parce que parfois ils pensent qu'il faut
enfermer
donc c'est dans la saisie les normes au
patin oui
c'était je me suis tu façon je suis en
effet il ya des gens qui disent toujours
il faut alors dans la même veine il ya
un autre mot du jury donc dont je parle
d'ailleurs été dj locaux et vous
comprenez un film qui s'appelle le match
ben oui mais le gars août cindy lopes de
son nom et est doté dit que c'est
c'est un film qui est assez tranquille
sur la maladie est bien le personnage
dit c'est la vie qui est compliqué c'est
pas moi qui suis compliqué et je propose
en voir un petit extrait justement ça
fini
[Musique]
dans ma tête je suis désabusé parce que
j'ai l'impression que surpris par le
temps qui viennent ils vont vite une
copie le temps pour vivre il pense qu'à
soi pendant deux ans aux autres c'est
chacun pour sa poule
et la pression qui se passe ce peut-être
qu'ils s'aiment pas peut-être que c'est
la façon d'un jaune
imaginez mais vous avez un peu bizarre
comme si j'étais pasteur dans ma tête il
faut jouir c'est pour ça c'est pas un
faux sujet comme ça c'est la vie est
compliquée c'est pas ma came indiqué
celle qui est compliqué c'est maman qui
l'a enlevé
c'est la vie qui est compliqué
bah oui mais le gars août c'est un film
de yves au pouce et eric altmayer et
revient vous
parlais justement des fictions et vous
parliez aussi de danser sorte de fiction
des films d'animation il y en a
quelques-uns et gagnent 2 qui vous ont
hâté qui ont attiré votre attention
c'est peppers boys et d'ours polaire
alors commencer par peur boys pourquoi
il ya de quoi il vous a marqué j'ai
trouvé que
j'ai trouvé encore une fois que le
message était très fort
s'il ya de tous les films de la
sélection 1 qui illustre vraiment
parfaitement le côté il faut bien vivre
avec c'est celui là quand bien même le
contenu quand même un peu noir y un peu
un peu un peu triste quand même et le
procédé de l'animation encore une fois
très très simple sur la base de la mer
et les moyens du bord et les réserves et
taper mes mails
là où je moi j'ai trouvé du cinéma c'est
que donc l'animation repose sur des
petites figurines qui sont animés par
les doigts du réalisateur mais on en
oublie le procédé et on finit par
rentrer totalement à l'intérieur des
pensées du du protagoniste
et et pour arriver à ce petit prodige en
fait sur la base d'une animation papier
mâché très simple c'est du cinéma et
c'est le réalisateur s'appelle peter
burke verra vera wang et on voit d'aucun
un petit extrait de paix par boy
sans toi je me reconnais même pas
mais surtout
il m'a même le foie
[Musique]
pure sans toi
je crois bien sûr
j'ai dans le dégoût mois
non
mais pour moi
over
votre film d'animation qu'ils auraient
remarqué c'est le réveil de l'ours
polaire de ian qu'elle rêve
oui le réveil de l'ours polaire c'est un
film qui a la particularité pour le coup
de vraiment s'adresser
aux gens normaux normaux pattes
qui
fait pleurer le récit le récit et eddy
par une personne qui se qui se remémore
comment son père s'arrête là
diagnostiqués sont des polarités sa
bipolarité donc on est nous mêmes dans
les pas de du narrateur et on découvre
en fait avec lui le les symptômes et les
effets de cette bipolarité et en même
temps le
beaucoup d'amour et l'affection quand
même qui unit encore les deux
personnages alors un extrait de le
réveil de l'ours polaire
comment j'ai compris
que ça remonte à l'été 2003
dans un camping car mon grand père
conduit et ma grand mère et mon frère
sont à l'arrière et moi je suis devant
comme un côté de mon grand père en train
de regarder la route anxieux parce que
ma mère avait appelés pour nous dire que
c'est tombé malade dans la nuit donc ils
vont lire la suite voilà c'était
évidemment des très courts extraits
alors maintenant on va on va voir d'aidé
financier parce qu'on va passer au
palmarès
allah il ya trois prix dans cette
édition le prix du public le prix du
jury et le grand prix on va commencer
avec vous de retire par le prix du
public alors vous ne les pousse pas je
vais battre
pour le prix du public en a choisi
celui-là parce que déjà cette animation
et on a trouvé l'image très très belle
et aussi et traite et traitent de sujets
de l'alcoolisme
évidemment à de fortes lien avec de
santé mentale mais je pense que suivant
quand on parle de de la santé mentale en
ont surtout à la dépression à la ville
puis pour l'arrêter de choses très
spécifiques mais comme le travail de
jean christophe et jean pour moi les sdf
formant les alcooliques et les
toxicomanes du chat ça revient
directement à
nos problématiques de la santé mentale
donc le prix du public ces alcools mon à
mort de romain millet et oui on a le
public a évidemment adoré ce film et
nous aussi on l'a vraiment on a vraiment
aimé demeure le regarde
la première fois que je les rencontre et
elle avait 16 ans on s'est croisé à la
soirée d'un de ses amis
elle est venue vers moi on a discuté
mais pourtant quelques d'autres
elle est partie je les ai pas revus
avant plusieurs mois à une autre soirée
on n'était pas plus proche que ça va
plus tard quand elle emménage avec son
copain on a commencé à y voir un peu
plus les week-ends essentiellement
parfois en semaine après les cours
s'arrêtent alors
jusqu'au jour où il a quitté
de lui tomber dessus
[Musique]
c'est là qu'on a commencé à musculaire
on se voyait plus souvent on s'échange
des plus longues plus dense
je sentais bien que cet acharnement
à défendre
je me suis installé chez elle
je combler un vide en quelque sorte je
lui redonner confiance
je l'éloigner de ses problèmes un peu
plus chaque soir
au moins autant qu'il orne et au visage
le matin
alors plus d'un jour sans fin ces rames
en plus une soirée sans flou
rien de plus fort que son amour pour moi
ray
toujours ce silence
notre secret
j'avais le contrôle
de ce qu'elle me disait j'étais même
dans ses rêves parfait
d'ailleurs lors de capter tout changé
entre nous je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya vu
ce qu'a dit faisait
l'humeur était trop
car du fragile impuissant jours puis
éveillé battant déterminer le l'homme
on me fait comprendre que je ne l'étais
pas indispensable finalement
je l'empêché d'avancer que j'étais
toxiques
j'ai tout fait pour le retenir
j'ai cru y parvenir certains moments
mais c'était devenu trop dur
elle avait brisé notre secret quetigny
science
elle avait rouvert les blessures que je
cachais si bien les a mises au grand
jour pour que d'autres les apaise
puis leur ferme
je n'avais plus de réponses qu'elle
n'avait pas déjà trouvé
je n'étais même plus une option
je suis devenu comme l'un de ses
souvenirs que j'aimerais s'effacer
[Musique]
c'est elle qui m'a nourri
alcool mon amour donc qu'ils aient reçu
le prix du public
on va passer maintenant au prix du jury
et le prix du jury le grand prix que
c'est quoi la différence si on peut
discuter je pense que le grand prix
c'est celui qui fait le grand prix voilà
c'est un peu comme un cadeau fin d
argile les invités entre nous tous chez
mémé le prêt de juristes vous avez
souhaité mettre le voilà le l'accent sur
un film
ce prix du jury c'est peut-être avec
vous qu'on va parler je savais que parce
que le fait parce que le prix du jury
c'est il il a été aussi désigné parce
que par rapport à ce dont on parlait
tout à l'heure c'est effectivement une
presque dans la sélection finale la
seule fiction la seule véritable temps
de 10 de fiction et c'est elle c'est
comme on le disait c'est pas facile
justement de de créer une fiction à
partir d'un thème au départ quand même
assez assez durs et les deux
réalisateurs
killing rosset et pablo
compris ce parti pris et le film est
assez drôle il joue effectivement avec
il joue avec les
les la façon dont les autres nous mêmes
voyons justement les malades dit mentaux
et il montre bien l'absurdité souvent de
ce traitement
on a tous bien aimé ce film je pense
qu'il aurait pu même aller plus loin
dans le palmarès s'il avait été un peu
plus abouti sur le plan 6,6 je suis
cinématographique il ya là la
réalisation et le jeu des comédiens sont
un peu hasardeuse mais le film est
réussi et là aussi au peuple de dorment
au patin c'est de réaliser ce
alors vous n'avez pas dit le sous titre
le titre cède près pour une rave leurs
deux nouvelles journées c'est donc de
kevin gross et et pablo gautrain et
c'est le prix du jury et on on le
regarde ce film
bienvenue sur il faut bien vivre et que
sa maladie psychique programme reconnu
dans le monde entier
bonjour nicolas comment vas-tu ce matin
mon prêt pour une nouvelle journée oui
oui je suis prêt
la tendance du jour thierry jean pour un
look cool et décontracté prendre soin de
soi c'est important
manger sainement permet d'avoir un bon
équilibre de vie c'est la qualité coûte
quoi on m'a continuation mais ce que tu
connais ce programme aille et c'est
effectivement la propose d'accord il
t'en penses quoi en fait bah moi
personnellement j'ai pas trop kiffé mais
après c'est une chance que tu en penses
d'accord ok bon faut que je file un
rendez vous je sais qu'une bonne journée
à ce soir
soit agréable et bon voisinage parce
qu'avoir un environnement sain
bonjour madame comment allez vous
on n'est pas en deux temps maladie soit
transparent et fais-toi confiance elle
fait partie de toi mais tu n'es pas
qu'elles sont d'accord là c'était mon
tout la vaste échelle mes copines et du
coup voilà et toi alors pas besoin de
plus surtout bah écoute tu sais depuis
que j'ai appris pour maladie psychique
je prend plus de temps pour moi et j'ai
démarré le yoga donc c'est cool mais
ne perd pas le contact avec tes proches
ils sont un pilier solide at on des
[Musique]
questions que ça aurai je t'assure
théorie
non parce que j'en ai pleuré toute la
nuit maman est très inquiet que ça nous
a tous bouleversés ce qui t'a rien
je sais
n'oublie pas tes médicaments le
traitement fait partie du processus
[Musique]
et celui-ci vous savez comment le
prendre parce que c'est pas des tic tac
ils mangent du salon japan
a effectivement bas je recommanderais
stable tandis que vous savez à chaque
fois vous ne dévaliser un personne
suivante s'il vous plaît
d'accord on s'est loupé collabore avec
le corps soit ils sont là pour t'aider
bon je n'y a plus de médicaments
allez on va vérifier le pilulier voir
comment ils se déroulent là
bas non mais là ça va pas du tout ma
nicolas hulot rock mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire bah je suis
désolé mais en fait le pharmacien mais
plus de stock virton tout à l'heure
on ne le fait pas c'est l'un voit la
fait pas
après le contexte professionnel de la
forme sud aiguë il y a quatre ans actes
aux toreros agressif majeur
recrudescence des troubles est la
décompensation je comprendrais bien
l'importance de l'observance même si
cela entraîne chez vous et jr brady
psychique catalepsie ils sont là pour
des béarnais rêve d'avoir à vous
annoncer une hospitalisation des
nouvelles hospitalisations c'est clair
pas question non plus très clair looper
mon petit gibert j'ai été clair un
espace plus parfaite même rigueur
c'est une bonne journée
après à la 7e journée
franchement
je fais poser une question tu fais
comment seront bien vivre avec la
maladie psychique bien dit des choses de
la vie et après pour le reste c'était
groupe
iliad est coté drôle de nom ce fut une
affection permet plus de un peu plus de
communes i way absolument oui oui
probablement plus que le plus que le le
documentaire suggère donc c'était ce fut
une saleté s'appelle prêt pour une
nouvelle journée et bien maintenant on
va passer au grand prix
alors qu'ils vont parler c'est peut-être
vous c'était prévu que ce soit font
qu'on parle mais les ballons
mais vous pouvez changer aussi vite
parce que c'est après tout c'est ce que
la mini limité il a été haut
presque oui
je pense qu'il a fait l'unanimité parce
qu'effectivement deux ou trois déjà
je pense qu'il est et il était en
premier pour tout le monde
alors effectivement c'est un film
d'animation
qui
finalement
nous parle de notre année qu'ovide du
confinement et d'une manière assez
sensible dans la mesure où finalement
c'est ce qu'on a tous on a tous été
confinés qu'on a vécu pratiquement tous
comme des psychotiques à se mettre à
distance passe touchée puisse embrasser
surtout pas sortir de chez soi et moi
j'ai beaucoup de patients qui m'ont dit
mais finalement c'est notre idéal enfin
je veux dire c'est comme ça qu'on vit
vous enfin vous vivez comme nous et le
film aborde un petit peu ça avec drew ya
d'autres éléments dans finition est
intéressant mais finalement il ya quand
même cette pop et là par la création je
trouve qu'on touche à ça on est tous
dans le même bateau mais on est tous de
la matière le film se termine un petit
peu comme ça mais on on s'était preuve
qu'on a vécu 90 ans dans l'année
beaucoup de psychotiques monde y met ses
notes c'est notre mode de vie
après il ya ceux qui sont bien délirant
qui on est je vous l'avais bien dit
qu'il fallait être comme ça
qui fait les tifs qu'il fallait pas il
faut rester respecter une bulle autour
de nous par désir de protéger la santé
des autres donc il ya bien peu ça dans
le film et en plus la loge en veut dire
le rythme la voix fle tout est vraiment
très très très très très réussie et moi
je trouve très esthétique très beau et
pas deux secondes ennuyeuse mais
peut-être que mes collègues on s'est
fait je me suis là quand même
je pense que ça m'arrive le grand prix
dans cette année parce que c'est un ami
qui était tellement marqué par le cos
ville et qui voilà qui à l'heure plus de
conversations sur la santé mentale de
tout le monde et des conversations
answer comment on peut vivre bien en
général comme qu'on peut aussi faire des
choses pour éviter de tomber dans les
maladies sic si chic et donc je pense
que ben il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de
films qui étaient très intéressants mais
celui là pour 2020 je pense que ça mark
laneve nathalie marquay pernaut
bien c'est un film de
etienne du son est à vesoul paula à
monza
il faut qu'ils ne rencontrent honteux
lui les réalisateurs est étudiante en
arts plastiques
est passée elle qu'il fait là oif
d'ailleurs
en tout cas pour la vie ont
raison parce que la voix c'est souvent
un piège c'est souvent un artifice un
peu facile il cherche à dissimuler des
play offs je crois que c'est sofia
surtout et là il ya une très bonne
interprétation lavaur
et ça c'est une grosse différence
absolument alors je vais on va le
regarder dans un instant je vais vous
remercie je vais demander après à
laurence du pain de re venir me
rejoindre pour la fin de cette remise de
prix pour la conclusion merci merci à
tous les trois mois si on retire l'unpi
câble merci jean christophe pignol et
merci eric altmayer et on regarde donc
ce grand prix qui s'appelle la
compréhension de l'argile
au début ça arrivait de nulle part on
savait que ça existait une personne ne
l'avait vraiment vu venir
c'était comme ça il fallait rester chez
soi
tout paris était devenu dr il y avait
comme quelque chose dans l'air qui nous
disait qu'on pouvait plus sortir
certaines personnes je vivais mal je
trouvais ça drôle presque bizarre
comment pouvait tout ne pas émettre chez
soi tranquilles sans autre souci que
celui de penser à la vie et de s'occuper
de ces projets
moi j'ai toujours aimé ces moments où
l'on est isolé peut-être parce que je
suis plus habitué que les autres je ne
sais pas il faut avouer qu'à cette
période la télévision des départs
relativiser le vieux c'est est
omniprésent dans les médias c'était
comme un tunnel on ne savait pas quand
ça allait finir
j'avais peur de sortir je ne pouvais pas
aller plus loin qu'au bas de marge je
crois même que je préférais rester
enfermés
parfois le bruit rentrer mon anxiété
aussi ma voisine est au téléphone toute
la journée je ne sais pas comment elle
faisait depuis avait ces oiseaux aussi
qu'ils n'arrêtaient pas pour railler
c'était difficile je ne vais pas me
concentrer
pourtant je devais trahi j'avais des
devoirs à rendre pour l'université
mon problème c'est que je n'arrive pas à
vendre des trucs passable et je ne dis
pas ça pour me vanter ça me pose
vraiment problème en fait je n'arrive
pas à faire pour faire si ce n'est pas
bien si je ne suis pas fier de moi je
préfère ne rien rendre mais évidemment
si je ne rend rien je ne peux pas
valider mon année cette sainte ide et de
redoubler me terrorise et évidemment
comme mon anxiété augmente fille
n'arrive plus à rien faire
je sais que je dois quitter cet état de
stupeur mais comment je suis trop nul
j'ai pensé plusieurs fois au suicide
j'ai même déjà essayé je sais que c'est
une erreur mentale pas une envie à long
terme mais sur le moment cela apparaît
comme la seule solution pour changer mon
état et je dois changer je ne supporte
plus pour tromper le temps parce que je
sais que c'est crise finisse par passer
je me drogue avant vous prenez de
l'alcool mais ce n'est pas bon à force
cela ne fait qu'empirer les problèmes
maintenant je prends des médicaments
mais j'aime pas ça me fait de venir à
légumes je préfère la marijuana ça me
détend plus mais comment je peux
trouver de la marijuana en plein
confinement
il faut que je fasse autre chose que
j'appelle quelqu'un qu'on vienne m'aider
mon ami m'a dit que c'était une connerie
que les ambulanciers les infirmiers et
les médecins ils ont mieux à faire que
s'occuper de moi avec ce satané virus
qui est dans l'air
je ne sais plus quoi faire je me sens
seule je me sens moche je me sens sale
je me sens inutile
alors je préfère me recouvrir le cachet
du monde être encore plus confiné que le
confinement
puis peu à peu sous la couverture comme
écrit dans les pleurs dans ma barbe dans
la crasse je crée un autre monde je me
coupe du vôtre je suis désormais entre
le réel et l'irréel le rêve et la
réalité j'ai fait le vide je ne suis
plus rien plus rien si ce n'est de la
matière organique et son but
peut-être que c'est ça au fond la vie la
matière organique sans but et son sens
qui est comme aller et qu'on doit juste
accepter prendre tel quel il ces deux-là
travailler pour peu à peu relevé la
couverture et rapatriement tel que l'on
est rien de plus rien de moins
rien de plus rien de moins c'est donc la
compréhension de la risle qui a obtenu
le grand prix de cette troisième édition
l'heureuse du pain les bancs du gerec
disait c'est vrai que c'est un film qui
est assez situé dans cette année
particulier est-ce que d'une façon
générale la situation qu'on a tous vécu
influencé délai les cinéastes et les
auteurs de ces courts métrages qui vous
avait présenté à mon avis oui parce que
si on avait plus de films d'animation
aussi c'est peut-être aussi dû aux
difficultés à créer des groupes à se
retrouver et on s'adresse aussi à des
étudiants qui souvent ont créé ces films
dans le cadre de deep le travail de fin
d'études je pense qu'ils n'ont pas fait
dans les mêmes conditions que d'habitude
mais bon voilà c'est c'est aussi très
intéressant d'avoir de l'animation parce
qu'on dit des choses autrement alors on
a vu quelques heures quelques extraits
de films on a vu les trois prix le prix
du public qui est le public vote en
ligne ce soir oui c'est ça exactement
fait on ouvre la possibilité au public
de voter une fois par jour pendant une
durée limitée pour tous les films de la
sélection donc en fait c'est vraiment le
public qui décide new kick y aura ce
prix de ce qu'on a une loi un décompte
essais c'était tellement transport de
produits tandis que le prix du jury et
le grand prix mais il ya tout
il ya beaucoup d'autres par d'autres
courts métrages comme voilà qu'on n'a
pas évoqué qu'on peut voir comment les
gens sur le site oui exactement si c'est
un peu justement les limites de notre
présentation de cette année c'est aussi
dû aux qualités que finalement
malheureusement peut pas rencontrer les
réalisateurs déjà gré de ne pas l'avoir
eu l'occasion de remercier pour ça qu'on
a fait cette remarque le mans tout comme
les membres du jury que je prends a été
content des rencontres et réciproquement
et malheureusement donc on ne peut pas
diffuser tous les films on a diffusé des
extraits de certains en entier et
j'ai peut-être les sites et oui voilà
j'hésitais sociaux qui ont quand même
été remarquée qui ont été ses lectures
de partie de la sélection et que
j'espère qu'on pourra diffuser dans
d'autres conditions dans d'autres
festivals ou dans d'autres présentations
et qu'on peut voir sur le site et vidéo
world il reste en fait sur le site
d'entraînement par convergence points
comme le chant elle donnera donc je vais
décider il ya les eaux qui a été réalisé
par une équipe d'élèves des beaux-arts
de paris
7 12 lignes et
deux films qui sont clairement sur la
manière dont la maladie psychique et
vécu qui s'appelle le premier qui
s'appelle iso perception subjective un
autre qui s'appelle rétablissement
monstre sans son titre faisant dire ce
qui vous dit un autre encore délire sur
la vie avec une maladie comme la
schizophrénie qui s'appelle la couleur
des iris
encore un autre aussi sur les maladies
psychiques dont c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'ils sont des non
pas été dans les premiers c'est qui
c'est vrai qu'ils sont la section
particulièrement dur et noir et yaël qui
est un très beau film aussi qui parle de
voilà de la vie avec cette maladie
qu'est qu'est-ce-qui ce thème de l est
et enfin stigma qui parle aussi de la
stigmatisation
moi j'ai trouvé poussé cmax gg page pas
signer à spa réalisatrice c'est pas mon
métier j'ai trouvé globalement il y
avait une qualité de réalisation cette
année qui est exceptionnel et que même
ses films que vous n'avez pas pu voir je
vous invite à aller les voir sur le site
parce qu'ils ont quand même tous des
qualités de de travail de deux messages
qui parce qu'ils sont particulièrement
intéressants vous me regardez peut-être
pas tout ce qu'ils ont à la suite des
autres mais
j'aurais
évidemment il y aura il y aura une
quatrième édition l'année prochaine oui
on espère on est en train de l'organiser
en général le prix ce serait se montrent
sur deux années c'est que lance le
premier appel à projets qu'on élabore
déjà dans les premiers mois pour ce qui
est du contenu des visuels et autres et
puis après mois la csc se monte à ap il
faut retrouver ses copains chose pour
encore exactement très simple tu as fait
écouter merci merci infiniment
voilà c'était c'est une bonne cuvée
s'est trouvé de 2020 j'ai trouvé très
important c'était assez intéressant
aussi d'avoir à s'adapter à ses atouts
ses nouveaux formats et d'ailleurs je
vous remercie de vous accueillir sur un
plateau parce qu'on a des chances de
pouvoir le faire sans masquer ce qui est
plutôt bien en ces temps harding
et on est quand même très content de
pouvoir remercier les réalisateurs de
cette manière en espérant qu'on pourra
toujours voir en 2021 dans de bonnes
conditions et dans une salle de cinéma
qui devait être le bouc ça qui est allé
je rappelle quand même les prix ceux des
films côté de primes et donc le prix du
public sert alcool mon amour le prix du
jury c'est prêt pour une nouvelle
journée et le grand prix c'est la
compréhension de l'argile merci
infiniment laurence du pain et des mon
travail pour l'année prochaine ou déjà
merci
[Musique]
ils d'europe
rome
[Musique]
ici